welcome to another episode of ask mr
wonderful
as always it starts with a question or
sometimes questions
this week i mean i love this this is
from
cindy rose hi mr wonderful
i got into your channel recently and
i've watched the last seven episodes
you spend a lot of time talking about
the traits of successful people
and for the most part i have enjoyed the
shows but you really leave a lot out
what about diet what about exercise what
about fashion what about grooming what
about drugs what about
alcohol what about sleep i'm interested
in where
all these fit into a successful
lifestyle i really think you should take
the time to answer these questions
because i'm going to bet many other
people want the same
information okay
grooming this is an interesting one
i feel that when you get up in the
morning
and you work out you know my routine is
i get up i work out i have breakfast
i get up pretty early i get a lot of
work done early on i get my three things
done
but before i go out particularly if i'm
gonna spend time outside
one of the problems i've got is i'm
always putting on
makeup i have makeup on right now
generally i put it on and i got a lot of
real estate you don't want to be shiny
on tv so i'm putting this stuff on my
you know my my golden dome a lot
and a ton of it under my eyes like this
and around my nose and here where it
gets shiny
if you see people that are on tv they
look great on the camera when you see
them in person
they come off the set they look like
they're dead they got so much makeup
packed on
you know i don't endorse products that i
don't use personally i just don't want
to do it
if i'm going to get a sponsor which i
have
you know on my youtube channel i'm going
to use the product i want to know all
about it
and i want it to work for me why would i
endorse it for somebody else if i don't
try it on myself you got to eat your own
cooking i really believe that
tiege hanley has a scrub that i've
really
started to use and particularly around
you know my eyes and my nose
and i mean you know it sounds crazy
talking about this but it actually
become part of my routine
the wash is a basic wash for your face
morning or night for me
and the scrub takes all the crap out of
my pores skin care for men
who knew i'm using it now because i want
to keep looking like mr wonderful
and naturally when i invite tiege hanley
to be a sponsor of my video because they
use their products
i want them to give a little certain
junior sequoia to my base i want them to
give you a deal i want them to give you
something extra special
so they're sponsoring this video today
they're hooking up my viewers with a
special offer just click on the first
link
in the description to get a free totally
drop bag with your first box
so you know i do a shout out for their
products because they work and i hate
perfumey stuff
and theirs isn't so i i don't want you
know a smell coming off it it's it's
just clean
good stuff so i'm you know i'm shameless
endorsement for them but
it's good i bring it to the idea of
grooming i'll tell you why
in your career in doing deals and being
an entrepreneur and being a leader in
being a great employee whatever you're
going to do
you want to walk into a room and you
want to feel good you want to look good
and that involves grooming and fashion
finding out what you like to feel like
what you how you want to present
yourself
when it comes to financial services like
oh shares and bean stocks and all the
fintech stuff i invest in
and i'm in new york i'm in la or i'm in
zurich or i'm in london
and i travel to these places for
business
i like the crisp suit look
i got a classic look some people think
i'm nuts it's always the same i got 25
of the same suits 25
the same shirts 25 type ins 25 black
ties
i vary my watches as you know they all
have red bands
and i've got a very broad collection of
watches but consistency is the red band
that's my thing
and i you know change my watch almost
every day sometimes three times a day
depends where i'm where i'm what i'm
doing you know i travel with watches and
i like to have a
sort of a fashion look and people say
well that's kind of nuts
why would you need more than one watch
why would you need to watch it all why
don't you just
um use your phone you can get the
perfect time off your phone it's always
accurate i get that
i like the fashion statement i like the
the art in the dial
i like the way it works with the
cufflinks so that's that's a that's a
grooming slash
fashion thing and you got to find your
groove you got to find your look
you can shake it up but people get to
know you
about whether you've got that that
vibe that fashion vibe you know
take barbara corcoran i know about
her she always is dressed real sharp
i mean she always looks spectacular
lori the same way these women know how
to present themselves and they have a
look
barbara's different than lori but i'm
just making an example of people i've
been working with for 12 years
i know when they walk out i'm not
talking about
on the shark tank set you go to anywhere
with either of them and they are dressed
to kill
i get it that's a certain persona that
they're projecting
that's a certain look i look around the
other sharks damon
really into some eclectic style but
that's his thing means the fubu guy
robert has a west coastie breezy kind of
thing these are all
and of course cuban likes to just wear
sweats because he's saying something
with that
he can wear anything he wants that's
what he's saying and i get that too
but the point is it becomes a little bit
about who you are
and i think you should spend some time
thinking about it
and and you don't need a lot of really
expensive stuff
and i always air towards buying
something really good and having less of
it
you don't need like 15 jeans you need
three fantastic pair
you don't need 20 leather jackets maybe
you need two
i mean that's my whole point my suit
thing i like the consistency of my look
so i wear that
you know i've gone overboard on watches
but that's just my own thing
but i'm trying to make a point about
something here that becomes part of who
you are
and it happens to you in your late teens
you start to get a
feel for the way you want to project
yourself and i think that's very cool
i think it's really really worth
thinking about make that decision
consult with others there's so much
stuff online obviously but it's it's
what
makes you feel good you know that's
that's what really matters what makes
you feel good what makes you confident
to walk out there and do your thing
that's how you should groom and that's
how you should
fashion up you kind of have to make up
your mind
how you want to present yourself and if
you're comfortable with the way you look
be cool with it that's it i mean look it
doesn't it doesn't mean it's going to
affect your performance that's not the
case unless you're some kind of
fine-tuned athlete or something
but i also don't want to let it drag me
down in terms of how i feel and how much
energy i've got i care about energy
levels that's what matters if you're an
entrepreneur
if you if you really want to if you want
to run
you got to have some energy and
sometimes and when i mean run i mean you
want to run through your day i don't
mean running around you can do that too
is exercise
energy to me and weight are somehow
combined and you know
i like everybody else tried dieting i
tried all the apps
what i found works is you have to get
into a lifestyle groove
because weight is really very simple
equation calories in
calories out and depending on how much
you burn a day whether you're burning
1600 1800 2100 whatever it is
you're going to either gain or lose
weight but you want to keep constant
weights so you got to kind of think
about that in the context of what you're
eating all day long because maybe i want
to only eat 2 000 calories a day
i don't want it to be 50 in wine so i
have to constrain myself in terms of how
much wine i actually drink
but my point is if you get into a groove
where you have to me i have a normal
breakfast i gotta eat something in the
morning
right after i work out and then i don't
eat anything again
until lunch and it's those in between
periods of snacking and eating crap
that's no good for you
that really helps you keep weight off or
packs it on
over a long period of time you've got to
look at it that way i don't really buy
into the super diet taking all the
supplements and all that stuff
i believe in good food i believe in food
in moderation but
i really want to be able to try
everything wherever i go
and just be pragmatic about it you know
if there's certain things that you're
allergic to
or you know non-dairy and all that and
then everybody says to me why don't you
become a vegan well i am a vegan
i'm a modified vegan i don't eat meat on
tuesday from
breakfast till noon hey it's my my tip
of the hat to vegans
i eat less red meat i eat more fish i
eat more chicken
i moderate it all but yes i'm modified
vegan
i like to say that anyways
my point is you got to eat well
not too much of any one thing and if you
can
you know and if you want to modify your
weight you have to do it over a
really long period of time like set a
goal of losing seven or eight pounds
in six months that's my you know you all
these diets you crash
diet loses crash diet with that that's
all you can do is crash
you gotta just modify your eating habits
slightly and it has a big impact over a
period of time
okay so let me tie that to alcohol for a
second because i want to talk a little
bit more about that
and i like cindy rose's question about
how this fits into a
successful lifestyle let's talk about
alcohol
let me give you some do's and don'ts
just from my point of view
okay i'm in the wine business i drink
but i never do it
when i'm working why
because it only takes one mistake
and you get cancelled and i don't mean
just cancelled off tv you can get
canceled out of life you've seen it
happen social media is cruel
people get drunk they say stupid things
maybe you shouldn't tweet maybe you
shouldn't go to insta when you're
drinking maybe you should really think
it through before you become public
while you're relaxing i'm not saying
getting drunk but
just some rules about drinking here's
some other rules i've interviewed
thousands of people in my time
i've never hired anybody where i could
smell alcohol on their breath
not because i think they're alcoholics
not at all
in my view this is a personal opinion
they didn't take that interview very
seriously if they had a drink beforehand
or maybe they had nerves and they
couldn't do the interview without having
a drink
that also i don't like in life you're
going to have to make decisions about
this stuff
and when you drink and basically for
most stuff you drink people can smell it
if no one else in the room has had
anything to drink and you have
people are going to smell it what does
that say about you
in my view not good things because
you've done it during the work day
now in europe sometimes when i go over
there to do business and around wine
and i'm in with with others in the
winemaking industry yeah we drink at
lunch i mean that's you know it's
sometimes a burgundian or you know if
you're in bordeaux that that's happening
but you're dealing with the craft of
making wine and you're in the wine
business
slightly different i'm in new york city
having a meeting with an executive or
talking to a producer about something
i'm working on a television
at one in the afternoon i'm not drinking
just not going to do it i can wait
and when the market's over for me my
routine is 4
4 30. i've been doing this ever since
i've been involved in financial services
yeah i'll go have a drink with somebody
and that's after the market's over
i don't drive anywhere after that i'll
tell you that but this thing with
alcohol
is kind of weird and i'll tell you why i
say it
i've got lots of friends that have
completely stopped drinking altogether
and i know why not necessarily
full-blown alcoholics
but it changed their personality they
were different
people even after a couple of glasses of
wine they were not
their original self and what would
happen is
the next day someone would say to them
you know hey listen
you know last night were you drunk do
you remember saying this or that
if that starts happening to you alcohol
is actually
changing your behavior if it happens
consistently
and people comment about it to you
you could have a problem not necessarily
being an alcoholic but letting something
like that
change other people's perception of you
alcoholism breaks up families destroys
wealth
causes huge fractions between friends
sometimes for lifetime periods
nothing tastes that good that it's worth
destroying your life over i don't care
what booze you're talking about
do not let alcohol define who you
are that's my advice on that great segue
into drugs
okay now drugs is a whole
different ballgame i don't do drugs
because
i don't like what it does
to my abilities to process information
my day is packed with stuff that i deal
with sometimes it's problems sometimes
it's opportunities
i don't want to make decisions when my
thinking is altered
now i know there's a huge debate about
cannabis and the merits of it
and all that i never invested in
cannabis why because all the companies
that showed me deals
never were able to separate the
medicinal opportunities should there be
one
with cbds etc and
recreational i don't invest in
recreational marijuana because it's not
legal in every state and i do business
in every
state and there's something called the
rico statute and it's a schedule one
narcotic
i don't want to fight with that stuff i
don't want to be involved in it so i
don't do it
and i don't invest in it someone said to
me recently hey wait a minute didn't you
invest in
psychedelics yeah i did i i have
invested in a company called mind med
which does
it's now public and it basically
is doing scheduled trials with the fda
level one level two level three
in micro dosing psychedelics to see if
in some way it can help with opioid
addiction or
anxiety or alcoholism and all these
afflictions that there really haven't
been any new drugs for in 35 years
that intrigues me because it's legal and
it's not being done recreationally
but that's different than drugs same
thing in that interview thing i talked
about earlier and i said okay wait a sec
you come to me and this has happened you
know sometimes very
interesting engineers come in i know
they're stoned i can smell it if it's
you know if they've
blown a joint they've had it i can smell
it
it's just me the answer is no
i don't care if we're in a state where
it's legal i don't like drugs
because i'm pretty happy just marching
on the way i am
and i don't want to change but i also
want to i don't take any risks
i don't want to mess with stuff that
messes with my head
just a personal opinion and you can say
well you know i like to smoke spliff
once in a while i get all that
i'm just telling you what i do generally
speaking the people that i've known to
be very very successful
they get high on winning they get high
on moving forward they get high on
business and being successful
i will say this about one drug that you
know
i've been around for years because in
the television industry you see this all
the time
you see it in the bathrooms whatever
cocaine that's a bad drug
it's a bad drug in every way i don't
know anybody that's been able to manage
that drug anybody that i know that's
gotten into it for a long period of time
it's been a real bad outcome including
death
really sucks but destroyed lives
discouraged marriages destroyed
businesses
i mean talk about changing behavior
talk about unhealthy i mean it's just
brutal and i get people's attraction to
it
but i don't believe that that's a drug
that you can have a little bit of
that's not how that one works so you're
going to have to make your own decision
but for me i don't want anybody working
in any of my companies
that's doing coke because i know the
outcome it's
never good and when i find out they are
i'm sorry that's
you know i try and get them help but
very often it's not a drug you can get
off easily and i'm just
i'm just saying i understand addiction i
got it
but if you have a choice is what i'm
saying and we're still on
the cocaine issue you don't find cocaine
associated with
success you just don't you don't
not over a short period of time or long
period of time so my advice to you
don't mess with it it's that simple if
you can completely avoid it do that if
you have to try it
be very cautious and conscious
of where it takes a lot of people to a
really
bad place okay last on cindy rose's list
was what about
sleep now i never thought about sleep
it was not a big deal to me sleep when
you can get some rest
then i joined this group called the
longevity league
it's it's a bunch of uh entrepreneurs
that gather together
every couple of months sometimes it's a
zoom call sometimes it's it's a dinner
depending on what city they're all from
different places so
sometimes they meet you know but they're
interested in understanding
how to maintain a really healthy
lifestyle both for balance of work
you know in life and everything else but
there are certain things you can do that
are very very healthy
and one of them is sleep now i never
really got into it but
rem sleep deep sleep how much sleep you
know
i used to think i don't need eight hours
sleep well you do actually
it really really helps you become a much
better and more productive person now
there's all kinds of devices on the
market um
you know there's there's watches i don't
wear those electronic watches i wouldn't
be seen dead with one
i prefer the art of a handcrafted piece
obviously
but there's rings and other things and
you put them on
this is one of them and it basically
tracks your sleep
and it's there's there's dozens of
devices you can choose whatever you like
but the point is monitoring sleep is
really interesting because
you start to realize certain things
about your lifestyle
i'm really good at taking a 20-minute
snooze in the middle of the day when i'm
traveling somewhere and i'm
in a car you know back of a limo or in
my plane flying somewhere
and i would have thought that's the same
valuable sleep
that it would be in the middle of the
night it's not now one of the things
about sleep you should know
and this is i found this out just you
know by just monitoring my own sleep
i love wine i'm in the wine business
i've talked about that a lot i love to
drink wine with dinners it turns out
the later you drink any alcohol the more
it screws up your sleep which is
heartbreaking for me because i just love
wine
and i've had to modify a little bit
instead of you know drinking wine
let's say i'm gonna have dinner at eight
o'clock or something or even worse it's
gonna be much later because
miami where i hang out quite quite a bit
it's a very late lifestyle sometimes
dinner's at 11.
um i don't drink at 11 o'clock at night
anymore because it totally screws up my
sleep it reduces my rem
sleep and reduces my deep sleep and you
can see the results off any device that
monitors your sleep
it's brutal so you know maybe you have a
drink at six or seven
i mean i don't know if you can do this
but i'm just telling you over a long
period of time
screwing up your sleep every night
because you're drinking is really stupid
that's my view so you have to modify
maybe your weekends you ignore this
but at some point you really don't want
to mess up your rem sleep and your deep
sleep with alcohol
that's the one big change that i've put
into my life and it's really helped me
quite a bit
it gives me a lot more energy in the
morning you'd be amazed how fantastic
you feel
after a solid eight hours sleep with a
good cycle of deep sleep
and rem sleep i mean you get up bouncing
out you're just ready to
take the world on it's fantastic what
screws that up
too much alcohol late at night or any
alcohol really close to when you go to
sleep
and i don't it's just the way it is i
mean you know it technically you'd be
better off drinking wine at nine in the
morning
which is crazy not recommending that but
you want to get it as far away from when
you're sleeping as you possibly can
either you give up alcohol completely
which i'm not prepared to do because i'm
in that business
or you modify your use of it so i've got
a couple of reasons for this the sleep
thing i don't want to do too many
calories knowing it's 160 calories
a glass so maybe a couple of glasses of
wine
three maxerino like that's max because
that's a ton of calories
but it takes a toll on your sleep so
that's kind of a little bit of a
snapshot about
how for you know cindy rose all these
things fit together you're going to find
that successful people
have one way or another dealt with drugs
dealt with alcohol worked out the whole
sleep thing and figured out grooming and
fashion they found a path to all that
and they made a lifestyle choice you can
too but it's got to be conscious
you're going to want to do that and and
for the guys that are you know
constantly worried about their weight ah
get over it i mean look as long as it
doesn't make you unhappy about the way
you feel about yourself you can be any
body style or any weight that's cool
but if you want to modify it which seems
to be an obsession with about a third of
the population you have to change your
lifestyle
there's no for me dieting just doesn't
work you know and i've
and it doesn't really work for most
people starving yourself making yourself
miserable really stupid
changing your lifestyle small
modifications watch over months how
you shed the pounds so we talked about a
lot of stuff on this
um i've dealt with all these issues
myself i've
kind of found my path bottom line let's
end it this way you want to get up in
the morning
and feel great about the day you're
going to be in whatever it is you do
and so much of that is based around
things you have control over
what you eat what you drink the drugs
you take
you know how much sleep you get
you were gifted with control over those
things in many many many ways
and it's really up to you to make the
decision to do it
or not but that's the part i like the
most about cindy rosa's question
pretty well everything on that list
she can do right or she can do wrong and
so can you
you know i got to admit i love doing
this because i think we're kind of i'm
learning
i'm reading questions it's a back and
forth thing keep them coming i really
enjoy it
take care my friends
the one thing about food that i want to
point out is it can be a fantastic
opportunity for friends and family i
love to cook
yeah chef wonderful i've made a business
out of that
cooking itself can be an absolute guess
what i love to do with family and
friends is make pizza
and it's just a party it's really
healthy food because you decide what
you're putting on it
i love to knead dough i love to just
work with it
i love to make pies it's just it's fun
as can be
and i probably do it every week wherever
i
am and believe it or not i invite
all kinds of people i do business with
to come over and we have a gas doing it
food can be fun and it can be great for
business and it can be healthy
hey what's wrong with that hey chef
wonderful here and you know i
love to make pizza you know what makes
making pizza even more fun
your own wood-fired pizza oven
bertello it's a shark tank deal i did it
i love the product but i also like
making pizza so we're going to do it
together
the first thing you have to do when you
make pizza is get all the fixin's ready
now i've got pineapple i've got cheese
i've got olives yeah i chopped these all
up myself a little green pepper
i like to do the mushrooms full size
because i'm an artist
the key to tomato is paper thin because
you're augmenting the sauce
and of course onions together you can
make any pizza you want
that means you need the dough i've been
letting it raise
look at these puppies
these are standard dough that i picked
up at the grocery store
i'm going to cut it in four to make 10
inch size personal pizzas
what i'm doing is i'm taking just
standard pizza dough that i got the
grocery store
and i'm basically cutting it into four
i'm not cutting into the wood here
i'm just severing it into four units and
that's going to give me
basically a 10 inch personal pie in the
eye
you want to have a little flower here
because that's how you stop it from
getting too sticky in your hands
this is what you're doing you see that
it's very simple and it's fun
it's fun the great thing about pizza
dough is you let it rise
under a little towel
and then you just kind of get think
you're thinking okay i'm thinking 10
inches
you can let gravity help you get your 10
inch
that's that's going to be a 10 inch
because it's about a quarter
a little flour on there be generous with
the flour
and then just start rolling it up
[Music]
i see you're ripping me off on my idea
with the olive oil
actually dad i'm pretty sure this was my
idea
oh each chihuahua it's been on for about
20 minutes
and the great thing about this oven is
it uses
listen propane it's a propane but
you can also put wood chips in it check
this out you throw in a wood chip
and it's going to smoke into the dough
you're going to taste it later
right inside the pie see that smoke
coming out that is
gorgeous
you know what go great with this pizza
some o'leary fine wine
the cabernet sauvignon the pinot noir
or the chardonnay which i'm having right
now i love chardonnay pizza
it just goes so well with the cheese one
second let me have a quick sip
oh it's just nectar
i love the chardonnay you know my wife
helped me blend this it's absolutely
spectacular now
the moment of truth let's take one of
these
slices of pie with all the cheese
dripping down
oh delicioso
maximuso that is the best pizza
i've ever made the cornmeal gives that
little texture
it gives that little run on the tongue
and then of course the splash of
delicious
the meats the sauces the cheeses
together the crispiness just perfect
that little olive oil on the crust
rotello pizza oven wood burning combined
with gas technology
and all of your favorite ingredients and
you too
will make a pizza delicioso
maximoso see you soon get your patello
and let's make pie
chef wonderful signing out how's the pie